parole est à notre collègue Vivette
Lopez pour le groupe des
Républicains merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues j'associe à ma question
mon collègue Alain Châtillon monsieur le
ministre je suis très surprise enfin je
ne devrais pas depuis le temps je dirais
plutôt scandalisé de constater qu'en
France lorsque l'on est vertueux que
l'on est prudent et économe l'état
beaucoup moins vertueux n'hésite pas à
venir se servir pour en récupérer les
fruits et c'est ce que vous vous
apprêtez à faire avec les retraites
complémentaires agir
Arco les réserves accumulées ont été
constituées par un effort soutenu des
salariés et sont le fruit d'une gestion
raisonnable elles assurent sur le long
terme la retraite des salariés du privé
faute de conduire des réformes
courageuses pour ramener les finances
publiques à l'équilibre vous allez pour
la deuxème fois fois piller les caisses
de l'agir à ces réserves n'appartiennent
donc pas à votre gouvernement aussi
Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous nous
rassurer et nous garantir que les
réserves financières de ces régimes
complémentaires ne feront pas l'objet
d'un prélèvement
indu ministre du Travail du plein emploi
de l'inertion Monsieur
Lop merci monsieur le président madame
la sénatrice vous m'interrogez sur la
caisse aire agir Carco et sur les
perspectives financières de celle-ci
d'abord je voudrais vous rejoindre sur
un point cette caisse est bien gérée
elle est bien gérée puisqu'elle dégage
des excédents et elle dégage elle dégage
d'autant plus d'excédents que depuis
2019 parce que cela a été voté par les
partenaires sociaux une déce une décote
temporaire de 10 % est appliquée et plus
d'un salarié sur de parti à la retraite
depuis 2019 et bénéficiant de cette CAE
de retraite a été touché par la décotte
nous avons présenté la réforme des
retraites avec madame la Première
ministre il y a quelques mois à tous les
toutes les étapes de la concertation
nous avons dit aux partenaires sociaux
que cette réforme était une réforme de
retour à l'équilibre tout régime
confondu nous savons aujourd'hui que la
GIR carkov va continuer à dégager des
excédents et nous savons qu'à horizon
2026 parmi les excédents sur le total
des excédents et nous ne parlons surtout
pas des réserves mais uniquement des
excédents annuels sur le total des
excédents 2026 un milliard d'
d'excédents sont dus à la réforme des
retraites qui a été adopté au printemps
dernier nous considérons qu'il y a
1illard millions d'euros qui vont
bénéficier à GIR Carco en 2026
uniquement par la réforme et nous
considérons comme légitime que cette
part des excédents liés à la réforme
puisse être mobilisé pour participer au
financement d'un régime de solidarité
les partenaires sociaux ont mis en œuvre
une discussion sur les règles de gestion
de la GIR Carco et ont fait un choix
différent choix différent qui se traduit
au même horizon 2026 par une
augmentation des dépenses sociales et
donc des dépenses publiques au sens de
la loi organique d'un milliard d'euros
supplémentaires nous nous devons faire
face donc à deux défis le premier défi
c'est voir comment nous pouvons
rééquilibrer les finances publiques pour
faire face à un milliard d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires et nous
considérons que ça n'est pas une
attitude totalement responsable nous
devons faire face à un second défi qui
est de garantir que la réforme que vous
avez voté qui est mise en œuvre soit une
réforme de retour à l'équilibre du
régime de
retraite
l monsieur le ministre sachez que ce
prélèvement est perçu comme un raquette
la solidarité financière n'est pas
entendable ce n'est pas au retraité du
privé de payer le gaspillage de l'État
en outre la ponction demandée par l'État
met en danger la pérennité des retraites
complémentaires et l'avenir des
relations sociales aussi si d'aventure
le gouvernement passé par la loi de
financement de sécurité sociale pour en
obtenir le versement nous serons là et
nous engagerons notre responsabilité
pour garantir l'avenir des relations
sociales et la pérennité des retraites
complémentaires
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]